Hale its engine catch here and today
we're gonna do a tattoo Tuesday video
we're gonna wear we're gonna actually
analyze the animal crossing data sets so
for these data sets it actually has four
of them where it comes with a critic
review a user review items and villagers
and I thought it'd be interesting to use
the tidy models and do some NLP modeling
specifically on the user reviews so
we're gonna load up the our markdown
we're gonna load anti diverse first okay
and since we're gonna do since I know
I'm gonna do some text mining and some
like NLP stuff I'm gonna load in the
tidy text package first and I thought
it'd be interesting to kind of show the
tight rein work of just making these
models and specifically kind of going
through you know the progression of like
predictive modeling for that stuff so I
think it'd be interesting to go through
you know tf-idf to figure out if it's
even generalizable then do the basic
lasso regression model and then maybe do
a stronger block box model and then
finish it up with like a Karass neural
network
so first we're just going to do a basic
EDA of the user reviews the user reviews
comes with a grade which is like a
rating the the user name who made that
grade the text review and also the date
so we don't really need a date we mostly
need the grade and the text so first
we're going to count the grade and make
a G teapot out of it so sequels grade
goals okay just so we can see a
distribution of the scores and we can
see that I guess me it might be just
with gaming reviews and stuff like that
or gaming user reviews but it's very
polarizing where people are either gonna
give it a zero or ten to me it almost
seems like a binary variable right you
either like it or you dislike it so
that's kind of interesting
it is a little odd because I thought
people really liked Animal Crossing but
you know you never know maybe it's just
an online thing so we're gonna actually
do some basic exploratory analysis on
text and I usually just do you know the
classic you know top 10 frequency for
each grade
geom column flip it you know yadda yadda
but I think it'd be interesting to do
maybe like a PCA analysis or some kind
of a clustering analysis and I was
looking at I'm Julia sillies blog and
saw that how she basically did her PCA
stuff and it's actually a pretty fast
way to do it so that's all we're gonna
do we're gonna do user reviews okay
we're gonna select the grade it was
great in text we're gonna tokenize it so
we'll say word text call out good would
will count every word for each grade and
then we'll ante join it with stop words
and - you know we'll remove the stop
words and I see if you see right here um
this is actually like I guess like
Japanese or or basically letters that
aren't familiar with our English
vocabulary so I'm just gonna filter out
all words that don't show up more I'm
gonna say these words must show up more
than five times so nice and equal 500
grand equals five so that removed most
of it I think yeah okay and then what
we're gonna have to do is we're gonna
cast we're gonna we have four thousand
tokens and we'll try it I'll try so
we're gonna cast this into a sparse
matrix or cast bars and we'll say row
equals grade column
equals word and value equals and what
this does is basically creates kind of
like this this matrix where you know
it's each each row is a grade each
column is a war it's is essentially a
document term matrix so we'll say a
sparse DF right and if we if we actually
look at the sparse to you you can see
how you know there's like all this stuff
all right pretty simple
okay so first to actually do the PCA PCA
analysis we're not to load up this
package called IRL ba and a basically
the reason why we use this package
instead of say like like carrots like
PCA I'm pre-processing is apparently
this this package really takes advantage
of the sparse matrix and makes it really
fast so that's what we're just gonna do
and we use the PRC comm RL ba we give it
our sparsity F I'm only gonna make about
four principal components we always
scale it these its nest
basically any I think any clustering
algorithm you should scale it so I'm
gonna say scale it goes true and we're
gonna do that it ran pretty fast
we can look at it so it has a principal
components if you actually look at it
oops I'm gonna stop this thing for you
to say class I'll show you I'll show you
that stuff maybe if we do structure yeah
I'll show you all this other stuff um
well I don't really care about that we
can just want to grab the actual
components so we're gonna say is PCA
text Center which if we look at it it
shows like you know a lot of stuff
what's actually to it so it does all
that does all that it's not in a great
format right so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna use the tidy format so it
ties it so we have our names our Center
I don't think we're gonna really use the
center yet so I'm just gonna
left the names and I'm gonna see I'm
gonna see buying PC PC a text and
rotation so what this does is it has all
the names and their respective principal
component values or essentially what
we're doing is gonna cost them so now
we're gonna ggplot it out
so our we're gonna compare the first two
principal components and we're gonna say
our labels are names and we're gonna
first do GM points to see if there's
anything so right now you can see there
is some clustering going on right these
are the principal components basically
try to explain the variation so it's
saying like okay we have these clusters
that can I explain it a good way to do
this is would is to GM label I know
we'll do a GM ID text right and we can
see right here that there's some
components right there they'll do stuff
like that maybe I might make it a little
bit bigger so I can see it dot high
equals 15 fig with equals 15 okay so
we're gonna do that do that cool
oh no it's doing this thing there yeah
so when we're looking at this what do we
what are we seeing
music caching complaint interesting um
what's this storage tree undistinguished
something undistinguishable okay lovely
it's stuff like that okay so we kind of
did you can see that there's there's
some type of cluster one thing that's
interesting is you can see how there's
this little curve action going on right
and then most and more centered around
here too
interesting so we're we did a basic pca
now is obviously you can go way farther
you can do more filtering you can do
other stuff you can you know you might
want to do a tf-idf and then assign
colors to it stuff like that you can do
whatever you want with it
but we're not actually gonna be doing
that so we're gonna yeah actually I am
gonna do that I misspoke so I'm gonna do
a group by grade and we're gonna take
the top 25 words so and N equals 25
ungroup boom see if that runs ran
somebody's this thing isn't working
again then now we see a better
explanation there's definitely some
defined clusters so you see multiply our
villagers system feels a lot makes sense
Island experience in Nintendo game
expand playing games people time
progress something about multiple player
and progress stuff so you can see that
there is actually some definitive
clusters in here that make kind of sense
make they actually kind of make a lot of
sense right which is pretty interesting
because you know it's not really doing
it's not really learning it's not really
learning actual text data text like I
don't PR natural language understanding
but it's just doing it through just a
basic PCA algorithm cool okay but we're
not really doing we don't have to worry
about that stuff um what we're gonna do
actually is we're going to first do a
chi F IDF analysis and this is because
we want to figure out if this is
generalizable okay so we did a clusters
to figure out like you know okay if
there's any interesting clusters and we
can kind of assume that there might be
relationship to grade but we should
actually find you know what are the way
distinguishable words for each grading
point and we know that grade is actually
kind of a discrete variable because it's
not continuous it's just and it's an
integer so we can kind of use it as a
categorical variable I'm not really sure
if that's the correct way to do it but
we can just do it for this ad hoc
analysis okay so we're gonna I'm Ness
tokens word oops
word text right you already know how it
is so we're gonna count grade or vined
yep idea was it word grade and group by
grade top and tf-idf n equals five
ungroup okay cool
what that argument word up to a greater
all right and I should also do an T join
stop words filter and it's greater than
equal to O and it's greater than equal
to five right cool
ggplot it out
x equals word y equals tf-idf bil equals
grade plus geum com+ scale X you ordered
faster wrap it out because he goes free
oops okay reorder within tf-idf great
okay obviously this is something that we
do all the time
oops cord flip and then we should
probably mutate grade equals AZ dot back
there great okay so this is obviously
there's something that I do a lot I
should probably create it just like a
little helper function I can do all this
for me but you know I like to waste some
time what are we seeing here ten bombing
wiggle off so what is going on here I'm
seeing a lot of Spanish words that are
making it a little a little skewed so
maybe people who who are writing Spanish
reviews were more likely to rate a
higher review but what we can see here
is that people who who who rate as zero
or very angry they're always saying
greedy ei force and greed company it's
not really about the game I would say
it's mostly about ei which is kindest
respectful to that came developers but I
don't know but we I think in the last
two weeks we went over tf-idf but we
also went over weighted it log-odds and
that's what I'm gonna do
he's realistically realistically uh okay
we kind of want to look at frequency
more than actual rareness because we can
see how it gets skewed based off of
these multi multiple languages right
it's kind of it's kind of messing us up
so that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna do that we're gonna do a pine log
odds and this is where it's grade
word and right okay we have all log-odds
and then what we're gonna do is throw
this in right and we're gonna have to
replace
tf-idf with log-odds not a big deal
right let's see if it's different
it should I would say it should be
different and that's what it does it is
different notice how there's less
Spanish words which is probably a good
thing because the majority of the text
reviews are I'm assuming in English so
we get a more accurate description of
what are the identifiable words for each
sub each grouping okay it's also got
bombing crossing amazing animal stuff
that makes sense
series so they liked Animal Crossing
they're probably huge Animal Crossing
fans they say it's understandable I
think there's probably probably talking
about I think was animal crossing they
had a late release may that this is I'm
kind of you know reaching but maybe
that's something to do with it so six
you can see repetitive poorly
interesting ramp I'm not sure what the
ramp if if that is a significant thing
ten I'm not sure what this is one Pete
talk wasn't quick harvest I'm not sure
again zero is still make sense though if
we see zero stars it's mostly about
saying something about being greedy and
they're kind of angry about the maybe
the company or the gameplay I'm not sure
but I think when we're looking at this
we we get well I'm thinking is okay well
if we take an account that the actual
ratings are kind of a combined area
thing where it's about ten and zero
where most if like most who are not
rating five six or seven s between this
median range and supposed to zeros and
tens we can see that there is some
distinction right here and it seems like
something that I think would be
generalizable on people are saying these
negative words are probably are more
likely to say give a bad rating who are
saying amazing I'm talking about the
actual animals in the gameplay are more
to rate a higher rate rating okay so
let's do that
yeah let's let's start doing some NLP
modeling so I don't be modeling 101 if
you don't know what model to do you
should probably just do a lasso
regression the lasso regression is a
century-old logistic regression but it
allows some feature illumination so you
can just kind of give it a large corpus
or a larger amount of feature sets and
just allow the model just select the
most relevant features and in this case
we're just gonna give it a lot of these
tokens and then it'll just kind of
remove the tokens that are unnecessary
worthless that's all we're going to do
we'll set our C to 42 we'll state ID
data yep
select and we don't want the user name
so I'm finally moving that one oh it's a
was it user review user reviews tidy
data now I'm not really sure the best
way to UM the best way to do these tidy
models to be honest I'm still learning
it but I kind of have it if okay
understanding of it what I do what I've
realized when I've been creating these
models is I have a lot of variables and
it seems like a lot of like one-time use
variables I'm not sure the best way to
do it but we're just gonna do it anyways
so tidy split initial split will say
tidy data and our initial split will DP
equals 0.8 just an 80/20 split tidy
trained training tidy split and then
we'll do tidy test testing
oops tidy tidy split cool so we have our
split data I'm gonna write that right
partition data now we'll create our
recipe so we'll say we'll call out our
text recipe right so now that I realize
we need to actually loading the text
recipes package this is just a another
package that's kind of a subset of the
recipes package and text recipes comes
with always cool things so we can do you
know basically tokenization without
tired text or it might actually you
sorry text I'm not sure but we have a
recipe way of doing it okay so text
recipe oops I will say recipe and we're
trying to predict grade based off of our
text our data is our tidy train so we
got that and we're gonna first tokenize
our our text Oh step step
token eyes and the thing that we're
trying to tokenize are is our text we're
actually going to remove our stop words
so we can do step step stop words and
with those tokens it will remove any
tokens that are in the stop words list
and then what we're gonna do is we're
gonna sue step token filter our text and
we'll say so we're only going to use the
words that we're gonna use the most
frequent 500 words okay so what are we
doing what are we doing right now we're
tokenizing awards or removing our soft
words and we're doing the token filter
now when I was doing this at first I
kept on running into an error saying I
needed a numeric and I thought the
tokenization will just automatically do
the term frequency however you needed
add that step so you have to say add
step term frequency you can also tf-idf
I'm just gonna do a term frequency right
so step step turn frequency there's
little odd because I thought since token
filter uses the max tokens of 500 I
thought it would
can I assume that it's already counting
it but it doesn't so you have to always
add step TF or tf-idf cool we have our
text recipe let's view it right tokenize
stop word removal text filtering term
frequency make sense we'll do text prep
text what recipe and then we'll prep it
right so that's gonna run okay look at
that
yep doing what we want
no missing data at 2400 data points okay
what we're also gonna do is this what
I've been doing for this um I'm also
going to throw in my cross validation or
um sampling for Caesar show cross
validation v-fold v-fold cv I'm will do
tidy train B equals 10 and also it
repeats equals 10 cool we'll get a
10-fold cross-validation repeated ten
times karat gold standard cool okay yep
repeat you can see there's 100 hundred
times dope now what I also want to do is
create the workflow right here so I
don't the alkalis okay it's worked well
right so work workflow we need you know
this is a thing that we always have to
add our workflow so we add our recipe
that we created and we have our workflow
right so now let's actually get into the
modeling stuff you know myself is the
best part but it also is the most
annoying part to me is because you have
to wait for it to train which is
annoying but we're gonna create our
lasso model okay and our awesome model
we're actually it's it's under the
linear regression right with our linear
regression we if you know we actually
have two things
our penalty in our mixture for our
penalty this is how much it wants to
like remove look how many variables it's
actually gonna remove depending on the
penalty parameter so we don't really
know that yet so and so on the wrong so
we're just gonna let tune it but for the
mixture we're gonna say mixture he goes
one and this mixture is essentially a
it's deciding if you want to do l1 or l2
regularization in this case since we
want to do a lasso its mixture equals
one mixture equals one basically allows
it to completely shrink the coefficients
to zero if you want to do Ridge
regression where you don't want to
remove all of it you would you switch it
to zero or I think if you want to do
essentially a elastic net which is
basically a combination of regional ah
so working both eliminate features and
also shrink them to a very small amount
you can do that where you can kind of
make it into a tune so make sure it goes
one is a la so make sure equals zero is
a ridge and make sure is tune is a loss
ik net I believe and first I want to do
this set set mode since we're trying to
predict the you know the the grade and
we're just gonna assume it's continuous
variable even though I was using it as a
categorical variable we're just gonna do
it as a regression problem and to
finally do it and gingi LM net so just
kind of going back on the mixtures of l1
and l2 regularization or last cell
versus Ridge regression when I first was
learning about last regression I was
kind of thinking like why wouldn't you
want lasso regression right it you know
the NP problem where you want it you
want to shrink you don't want to have
too many variables into your model and
it's better if all the spells that have
less variables right but the idea
between Ridge regression is if you're
creating these interaction effects you
don't want to actually eliminate this
source of interaction so you so one way
to do it is just shrink it very small
and that's what weird regression is good
at cool yeah so what's first proneural
awesome model to make sure it's working
yep we're doing that
Gyan that is
the engine that we I think we always use
and then we're gonna set a lasso grid
which is to a [ __ ] grid and since we
want to tune our penalty and I always
spell penalty wrong which is really
annoying
and we'll say level is equals uh this is
just for demonstration purposes so I
would say always equals ten okay now
we're gonna turn the model also tune
tune grid okay we give it we first give
it a workflow because it has to you know
read retrain a model give it the recipes
with all of our cross validated data
cross validation sets so ad model lasso
model then we give it three samples
equals cross-validation and then our
grid that we wanted to tune off of is
the lasso read I think that's it okay so
what it's saying is we're gonna train a
lot of model with the mixture equals one
and between the parameters given with
the grid that we created and we're gonna
tune it on all of these folds and we're
gonna average out the full average out
the results to get the best most robust
results this is gonna take a while I
think um because I actually did three
Peet's equals ten I probably shouldn't
have done that
but we're just gonna let it sit I'm also
gonna document some of this so say I'm
using weighted log odds and using way
too long God's using tf-idf say
clustering of the top twenty-five words
for each grade using PCA and visualizing
it okay say free
look oops look at grade distribution I
surprised but a lot wrong okay so that's
gonna be running I'm gonna cut this
video and I'll resume it when it stops
running okay my lasso model is finished
training I actually changed the
cross-validation so it only is just ten
folds and it doesn't repeat so that way
it decreases it by you know like ninety
percent
so we have our lasso tune we can kind of
look at that
oops comes with all our metrics um we
can kind of say pull dot that shakes
right our penalty when you visualize
that
but what's going on here now we'll just
tie it what that showed us I'll select
dot metrics tidy it oh yeah no way I
have to do the clock metrics what am i
doing
collect metrics boom there you go see
that's that's one thing that I kind of I
always forget that you cannot do these
weird functions and I already mentioned
in the video but we'll just we'll just
go through it spelled penalty wrong
again
cool doc oh oh I mean okay what are we
seeing we can see that right here we can
a penalty of I what is that point you
know 0.05 or whatever is probably the
best metric so that's what one day we're
gonna say lasso tune was it select best
metric and then we'll say our MSE
penalty 0.07 okay so we're gonna do our
best to n-- so last so fast tune okay
and we'll say final lasso model finally
and finalized bottle lasso model law so
that's two okay and then we're gonna
train up the final workflow so we'll say
font final lasso final actually lasso
we'll just call it last work flow work
well add recipe
ad model final a so model and then we'll
give you the final a so eval so lhasa
eval lasso workflow last fit tidy split
so now we're training the final lasso
model onto the data set and evaluating
it on the total training set and
evaluating so right so we can just kind
of uh was it can we do collect metrics
collect metrics yeah okay and we see our
our root mean square is three point four
seven again if you think about it it's
not great all right but it's it's
matching what our octal validation set
was doing so well we should do is think
about doing either a stronger model or
more feature engineering in this case
I'm just gonna do a stronger model just
for example sake so what we're gonna do
is we're probably gonna train up a rhino
forest model so that's what we're gonna
do so random forest model random forest
and it's in this case I really don't
want to go through the actual tuning
parameters of it so we're just gonna set
some things as the default so I believe
the the kind of standard rule for the
standard rule for like M tree or the
amount of features you want to use for
each tree is a square root of the total
features you have so square root of 500
tokens or 500 features is about 22 so
I'm gonna say 25 I'm also gonna use a
thousand trees just for you know why not
and then the minimum amount of samples
is just 20 that's completely arbitrary
but I just want to show you how show
everyone how that units kind of
train up a more powerful model okay and
since we're not really tuning anything
we're gonna do um well do uh we're just
gonna we're gonna train the model based
off of the cross-validation and kind of
evaluate the average risk average
metrics or average
yeah average metrics from those ten fold
validation so I'm trying to figure out
what was i calling it I'll say I guess
it's technically a Val no it's not so
I'll say random I'll say random or is
tune okay and this in this case since we
don't like tune grid right we're not
tuning based off something we're just
gonna fit it to the free samples so it's
actually called just Fitri samples we
give it our run a forest model we give
it the recipe and then we give it the
our cross-validation you know is
essentially like a recipe but we're kind
of giving it explicitly I'm gonna run
this I'm not sure how long it'll take
but I'll probably just um cut the video
and we'll come back when it finishes Oh
what the random four is tuned Oh random
forest model okay yep so I'll see you
guys in a bit okay so the random four is
finally finished training and I pulled
the tuning from it so we can see how ten
ten crossbow 10-fold cross-validation we
can collect the metrics right and we see
that the average root mean squared error
is two point nine right which is which
is a little bit better and since we
don't really have any tuning we can
actually kind of do the final evaluation
on the model so we can just close to
that final RF workflow
work workflow add recipe text ad model
random forest model okay and then we can
do with the final RF eval oops final RF
workflow and then the last fit tidy
split okay and we'll kind of compare the
the evals to each other I guess
just gonna set this up know what done
okay I will there you so we can do that
collect metrics 2.75 can I do let mutate
on that mutate model equals are yeah
okay and then what can do like a are
bind and then mutate monocles
was it lasso lasso right cool
so we have our metrics and then we can
just do a GG plot it x equals model y
equals dot estimate color equals model
pushy um calm about film let's facet
wrap don't metrics scales equals free
it's probably dot metric okay all right
so what do we see here higher r-squared
go root mean squared error therefore we
can kind of conclude that the random
forest model performs better than the
last of aggression and that kind of
makes sense if you think about it a
random forest can do a little bit more
complicated transformations to that data
but you know the random forest model
takes way longer to train the lasso
regression is pretty short you know it
can allow some feature engine feature
elimination so you can use use it to
kind of inform what type of features you
want okay so we say RF is has has better
performance than last oh okay
all funny dandy now we're gonna kind of
go a little crazy and do something that
I probably wouldn't recommend for this
type of data set but I've been doing
some using some Kara stuff and I thought
you know finally we can do some actual
NLP modeling or some neural network
stuff in Karis okay so that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna do first give it a
carrot we're gonna create a Karis DF
well deselect username so we have all
that his grades and text and what we can
do is we're actually know we can
partition it in some different ways well
first of all we need to do is the afro
tokenization and I'm kind of I I would
do it with text recipes but I'm not as
comfortable with text recipes + Kara's
comes with a lot of nice tokenization
feature functions especially since Karis
will take in different kind of forms of
data whereas tidy model is kind of
relies on tables or nested tables so
that's what we're gonna do first we're
going to specify our max features so max
features is going to be
two Maxima no words it's essentially the
you know max words that would max tokens
so since we're doing a neural network I
final was actually having a huge amount
of features so we'll say max which is
2,000 and now what we have to do is
actually develop a tokenizer so we're
gonna say tokenizer and we'll say text
tokenizer text oh I need a little
carrots when we're doing library
caris okay so then we do text tokenizer
are num words is equal to our max
features so this is our max amount of
words and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna fit it to our data so in this case
we're gonna do cares DF text why is okay
go so we have our tokenizer it's fit to
the text so it's finding out you know to
top 2,000 words most frequent words okay
and then what we're gonna have to do and
this isn't you know this is gonna take a
little bit because it's actually doing
the you know tokenization well we also
wanted to decide how we're gonna do this
and for me I'm gonna do a one honking
instead of the basic um bag of words
trick it's it's kind of up to the person
but we're gonna make the model a little
bit simpler so if we will get our
tokenizer oh we can see how it has all
this stuff right sequence of text stuff
for that sequence text generator splits
text matrix all that kind of fun stuff
we can kind of worry about that later
I'm just gonna do a one hot encoded
matrix so one hunt
results text to sequence
oh no text up text - oh it's text text
to matrix so we're gonna convert
Eric Harris TF text and stuff like that
to a 100 matrix I'm gonna give our
tokenizer tokenizer goal is twofold
our text will be caressed EF text and
our mode will be binary we can always
change it to frequency or we can do like
instead of a 100 and we do frequency I'm
just gonna do a binary matrix and that's
just because we want to make it simple
we want to Train really fast okay
I'm also gonna do a word index just in
case if we need to like reference the
predictions and stuff like that but you
probably won't be needing it but it's
nice to always have okay so we have that
what we need to do is actually split the
train and test sets and in this case I'm
just gonna use the carrot package
because I think the partitioning is a
little bit easier with this because you
get the actual row and it sees where as
I think with with that idea models they
don't only give you that stuff right
they kind of just give you the that
thing right so they have that but I
don't know I don't know if it's if I
should be doing it or not you might do
it and now we'll do it we'll do it why
not why not
we'll do it sorry about that I'm a
little indecisive about that stuff but
we can do it tidy in okay I know I'm
assuming tidy split L I D is the inverse
oh oh well okay so tie split in ID so
we'll say on what we need to do is
actually specify the X the training sets
are the training inputs the testing
inputs and the training how is it we
need to do with a train test inputs and
the train test outputs and these are
going to be defined as x and y ok so
we'll say X train and this in this case
we're going to do one hunt results
boom and we're going to specify all the
columns one hot results and then we'll
do the 1y train one hunt results and
it's time we're gonna ignore all the
indexes in the Train alright and just to
verify X train dim 2400 why train dim
599 cool and then what we're gonna do is
X test and that will be Karis DF grade
tidy split and switch in ID so we're
only grabbing the carrots the upgrades
that correspond ok that correspond with
all the train set and then we'll do the
opposite right
so anything that did was included we're
not gonna quit anymore okay
so X training gym X test length 2400
right and then if we do white rain Y
test they should be the same and they
are great um what we also have to do I
need it I'm just gonna go back here and
expand all this stuff I don't know the
shortcut to expand all of it so I'm just
gonna have to infinitely clean it okay
sorry about that okay so what we also
need to do is pad the sequences so it's
gonna give it I'm all this stuff but we
actually want a specific amount of words
in this case we need to figure out how
many words there are so if we look at
the user reviews on nest tokens word
text and then we just like count the
username and just do a summary we're
gonna find the distribution amount of
words for each review so on average the
average review length is 120 words so
that's what we're going to say so max
length will say the max length we want
is a hundred and twenty-one words in
this case I'll do 128 just because it'll
be like it's you know it's in the I
guess was it base 2 so max length is 128
and now we have to pad the sequences so
if it doesn't have 128 words it'll pad
it and I just add little spaces if it
doesn't if it has more than 128 words
kind of drop it okay so we'll do X train
had sequences X train X length equals
max length okay and then what we'll do
oh whoa I actually messed this up just
that X test sorry about that yeah and
then why why train my chest
yep okay sorry about that I had that a
little split so this is saying X train
next step the Train test sets for inputs
are these one huntress alts the train
test that's for the Y results are the
grades okay so we have had ex train and
then X test pad sequences X test max
length equals max length right and let's
see if we all right boom okay now since
we had our padding so we're going to say
create the X train and test inputs and
outputs also apply padding to the inputs
right so now let's actually create a
model so this will be our model all
right oh well model Karis model
sequential generally you're always gonna
do a sequential model since since we
have this matrix we always will we want
to create our own embedding so what we
do is layer embedding and this is what
you do for most text data and the input
dimension is equal to the max amount of
features which is our input dimension is
obviously going to be two thousand words
right because we're creating all one hot
encoded matrix of two thousand words or
two thousand tokens okay and our output
Kim and this is what is basically our
are embedding so we're gonna say sixteen
for now is a completely arbitrary and
that's when you actually would probably
tune it and input length is max thanks
because I'm accent goes on twenty-eight
with the amount of two thousand words
okay so what what is it doing its what
are word embeddings word embeddings are
essentially um ways that the model can
map out all of these tokens into a
representative state the biggest part of
the most common example is the word to
Veck algorithm or essentially can put
say king and queen in to the same
feature space it's kind of doing a PCA
clustering but it does it in a different
way I would say the the intuition I got
from layer embeddings
is basically a layer embedding is kind
of like a translator for the model to
actually understand the language and to
map it out to a prediction okay another
very famous word embedding model is the
Berk model which is a bi-directional LLC
model and that kind of does a lot of the
grunt work or people will use the Burt
embeddings as a source for their for the
top level model architecture so they'll
have a burp model which would be this
and then they would build upon you know
a generic neural network on top of it
which would use those embeddings which
allows it to the model to really
understand the text without training on
millions of data ok so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna say layer flatten
because it's in a 16 dimensional thing
and what we're gonna do since it's a
regression problem is just say layer
dense units equals one with no
activation function right it's just
gonna output the thing okay and I just
want to kind of go over this first the
main problem with NLP modeling is that
we actually don't have enough data so a
common thing that people do is use other
pre-trained models such as Burt word
avec which is just embedding
stuff like that and the idea is since we
don't have millions and millions of text
data to have our model actually our
neural network to actually learn or do
some NL natural language understanding
well let like people like Google and
Apple do that work for they have
billions of records of text data and
they're able to train models that can
replicate natural language understanding
and then we can use that model to base
to be the translator of a basic data and
build upon it because if you think about
when we're creating say our lasso
regression model we're not recreating
the algorithm we're just kind of using
that algorithm and tuning it and the
same thing applies with NLP modeling or
we're usually just it's usually easier
to use someone else's or some other
companies NLP model and build upon it
okay in this case we're not doing that
we're cleaning our own embeddings but
it's something that you should be well
aware of and it's a common trick in NLP
and in the NLP field ok so what we're
gonna do is look at them all first you
can see this is a very basic model it's
like a two layer model as an embedding
layer flattens it and then as an output
layer okay so what we need to do now is
compile the model I'm gonna compile it
our optimizer Oh will be rmsprop you can
use you know other things like atom
stuff like that but for this we're just
gonna do the baseline arm s prop our
loss function will be mean square error
and the metrics that we want to track
I'm gonna say is mean absolute error
it's the most easiest to interpret and
we'll just do that even though we could
use our MSC I'm just gonna do a mean
absolute here okay we compile it and now
we are actually going to do the fit so
history model fit and we'll say X train
Y train validation split so what we're
gonna do is actually split our train set
so looking kind of a validation set a
pox or amount of times it's gonna run or
say 100 on batch size oops
I'll say it's 64 why not so it's gonna
run the it's gonna run the entire data
set through the model 100 times using a
back prop to tune the model we're gonna
use it and each time we're gonna put
data we're gonna do increments of 64 so
it's gonna do it 64 divided by it was it
white 3000 so I won't forget Kara's ex
training
damn so 2,400 divided by 64 so 2,400
divided was 64 so it's gonna do like 37
times to count as one epoch okay so
that's what we gonna do fit okay so you
can see it's starting to run um you can
see it each epoch is going and we can
evaluate our loss we can evaluate our
losses and stuff like that so we can see
our mean absolute error is decreasing
our validation mean absolute error is
decreasing our loss is also insane
saying the relatives name okay it's keep
up it's going and going okay and we can
also go in our studio and kind of look
at it right here we can kind of just
view and step back and watch it watch it
train so you see our mean absolute
errors going down while our I would say
our validation mean absolute error is
kind of it's decreasing but it's a
little volatile okay let's hear what
we're doing okay so we have the at okay
and we can just do a summarization and
just say plot history and we see it we
can see basically our training
validation goes up goes way down see our
validation error goes down but it kind
of kind of plateaus right and there's
something where realistically we don't
have a very complex model or neural
network right it's only a few layers so
what we could do is you know create more
embeddings right we could increase the
amount of bending 632 ad another
activation layer and
see how that works but I'm not gonna do
that I'm just gonna I think this video
is getting a little bit long but we'll
just kind of evaluate because I think
that's basically where it's gonna stop
it's starting to lift a little bit but
validation mean absolute error is
lifting a little bit on average but
we're just gonna evaluate it that's all
you can say is I think it's evaluate
model give it the X test and Y test and
see what it does right mean absolute
error is 3.9 okay lets saying the model
is not great but the model is pretty
fast it was faster to train than most of
it and we what we were also using is one
hot and coded vectors on one way we can
increase our performance is probably
changed AK to a frequency we always try
maybe to a tf-idf we could also add more
things so instead of doing just wah wah
ha and credit vector we could do a
sequence of vectors so it could maybe
understand word placement and stuff like
that we could also increase the amount
of features and also increase the max
the length so yeah um so yeah that was
basically the you know a brief summary
of an LP modeling from lasso regression
to a actual neural network using word
embeddings I'll see you guys next
weekend tiding on